well you you actually glossed over one
of my favorite parts is because i
sometimes go to those beaches
you know you just go and you thought it
would be fun to propose on the beach
yeah we had been at a beach so we're
from new york you know i don't know the
layout that well in la
i know that malibu is nice from the 80s
so
i was i thought what's nicer than
something that was nice a long time ago
so i
i drove with my uh fiance anna or my
girlfriend at that moment
and i went to this beach off the pch
next to this restaurant called
gladstones
now in fairness to me we had been at
that beach a couple weeks ago and the
sun was setting and it was beautiful you
know and i thought if i had a ring i'd
propose right now
on the day that i took her the beach was
i don't know how to phrase this
crawling with homeless people
literally like one person like in the
beginning of monty python holy grail was
just digging in sand
angrily trying to dig to china and
we started walking
and you know and part of me was like is
this funny
if i propose here
[Laughter]
we're walking there's a guy and we get
to a point where i'm like i think
in the next 10 yards we might have some
clear space
we might have a window a window between
maniacs
and then a shirtless man walks to the
edge of the ocean and goes
and anna said there are a lot of other
beaches in malibu and i said that's
right
and so we got back in the car and we
drove way further down to another
yes yes oh my god so she was wise she
was very wise i mean she
knew i'm using it like the she knew i
was going to propose yeah do you
remember how she knew
[Applause]
no she knew what was up because i was
like you know
we gotta look it was all it was a
disaster i got on
we started driving and i said we're not
going to the airport you know i thought
we'd spend one more day in la
and like i have never done any kind of
surprise before so right away it was
just dead silence in the car and she was
like okay
and then it takes a while to get from
those feelers to malibu apparently so
we sat in silence in the car
[Laughter]
luckily my manager kept calling to say
my pilot hadn't been picked up
[Applause]
no it was worth it it was totally it was
really funny it was so
tense and then when i proposed it was
really worth it so a lot of it was great
what's up brandon and theo maritza
coming to you from johannesburg south
africa big fan of you both
um one of my guy friends recently got
engaged but his girlfriend proposed to
him
he said yes seemed fine with it so i got
a king kingdom stinger for you
girls proposing to guys thanks a
gang gang buzz buzz cheers love thank
you
oh that's australian running where's she
from south africa
oh my bad uh good luck out there man
it was luck out there south africa is
the wild
wild african no that's africa bro
she's in africa she's not in afghanistan
doesn't forget the end of it but it's
south africa
dangerous all of africa dangerous there
is
elephant some friction there i will say
that major friction that's true you got
to deal with
animals humans everything in africa
there's a lot of
cheetah take your kid oh yeah dude even
one of those strong uh willoughbys or
whatever those things are oh dude them
black water buffalo
harvey bro selling drugs
come across a [ __ ] hippo that's what
they deal with
we got gang violence out here they deal
with hippos and [ __ ] cheetahs yeah
we're complaining about mosquitoes dude
yeah
they have bad mosquitoes out there we're
complaining about a little fire on the
freeway
and these people are [ __ ] you don't
worry about the west nile virus
that's the top virus dude dude no wonder
she's saying girls proposing to guys
yeah cause they're
dying every day so like let's just do it
man
he's like oh wow i guess i like it i'm
an indecisive male you know i come from
a long line of indecisive males
and uh i'm surprised i'm even here you
know because
somebody had to make a decision or a
couple decisions had to be made and so
i think if a woman asks i like it
because then you can say yes or no
god i'm a little old-fashioned you know
i'm a little old-fashioned
especially it depends how the girl does
if it's like kind of sweet and just kind
of you know
is the right timing i guess i'm into it
but she does crossfit and she's like
real
bulky and [ __ ] she has calloused hands
and she gets down on her knee
yeah dude what are we doing yeah yeah
i don't want that oh no i know if she
like dusts off chalk she's like
let me talk to you for a second yeah
[Laughter]
yeah she jumps out of her chevy and gets
down on a knee
dude i'm out actually man the more you
bring it up like that
like when it gets to the actual physical
act of it
it's getting no bear shooting ella
embarrassing a restaurant
she wears a full rack of ribs you got a
salad with salmon on it
she gets down on a knee and all the
dudes like what the [ __ ] is happening
yeah and then she carries you out he
said yes
he said yes you're all gang gang buzz
buzz
that's true man you turned me out on
this one brother
okay do no you need to talk
to your friend okay i know that uh
there's some exceptions yeah if you're
in a coma or something like that
and you're lazy uh and she found the
ring you were gonna ask her
yeah and you're gonna die yeah that
makes sense and that's beautiful man
but yeah she gets out of a you know
truck leaves the truck
running and gets out because she has to
go back
she has to go back to work he's in park
and takes her construction hat off
gets down
[Laughter]
[Music]
wedding proposal advice uh
dare bill bald as my balls burr
all right somebody got the [ __ ]
manscape uh i discovered your podcast a
few months
back while working during this pandemic
shout out to all the essentials
um and i can't tell you how much
i've been addicted oh that's great thank
you i regularly tune in mondays and
thursdays and look forward every week
and i'm currently listening
to earlier podcasts from this year
pre-covet shitstorm
anyway i'm a 24 year old dude
and i've been with my girlfriend for a
couple of years now
and have been thinking a lot lately
about popping the question
we are both the same age and have stable
jobs and we don't see ourselves leaving
anytime
soon things are great in our
relationship
i am not yawning about your life just
yawning all right
i was interested in how your proposal to
the lovely nia went and how you knew
it was the right time and if you were
nervous um
i knew it was the right time because she
was gonna [ __ ] leave me if i didn't
i strung her along as long as i could
[ __ ] could i was terrified i
totally loved her and i wanted to be
with her but i was scared
um was i nervous i absolutely was
nervous
um i'm having trouble thinking of how i
should propose to her
but i know i want to i know i also know
she's everything i want
that she's definitely what's best for me
that's great you discovered it really
young
and she has my best interest in mind
thanks for whatever advice you can lend
and also thanks for doing the podcast
good [ __ ] lots of love from new england
and i hope your family is safe during
these times go [ __ ] yourself
um yeah i don't know
throughout the years with the internet
and the cell phone cameras
like people really
think they got to do like this big giant
[ __ ] thing i did not do a big giant
thing
um because i know if i st
if i if i tried to [ __ ] plan anything
she would have figured it out
so i went the opposite way
i believe it was christmas morning we
went on a hike back when we still had my
awesome dog gold cleodio and it had
rained out and it was all muddy and she
was pissed and we were going up this
hill and she just was
[ __ ] upset she was not having a good
time
and uh i had no plan i just knew i was
going to ask her on the hike and then we
just came to this rock
that had this it just was overlooking
downtown l.a
and i just told her to sit down for a
second i acted like i was
having trouble with the dog and asked if
she could reach into my pocket my jacket
pocket
and she pulled it out and it was uh
it was a little tiffany box or whatever
and then she went
you know put her hand over her mouth
and just started sobbing
um and that was one of the happiest days
of my life
not only because i did it and i felt
great and i knew it was right and i knew
it was the right decision
but also when you you know when you're
an
[ __ ] like me and your woman is always
mad at you
i just knew for the rest of the day she
was gonna be in a good mood
and i don't think i've ever had another
day like that
at any moment i'm telling you today i
[ __ ] i have this habit i [ __ ] get
a glass of water
i set it down on the floor i think to
myself bill don't put it on the [ __ ]
floor
you're gonna somehow knock it over and i
do it every [ __ ] time and i was with
my son
and i was bouncing him on the exercise
ball and i finally got him to sleep
and the exercise ball was in between
this little crib
so i i kicked it backwards with the with
my [ __ ]
you know my heel and i just heard it i
had a giant like you know
the [ __ ] workout level bottle
i just heard it hit the ground and go go
you know that little [ __ ] that sound it
makes and it's just the
[ __ ] water just pouring out and i was
just like you got to be
[ __ ] how many [ __ ] times you
[ __ ] stupid [ __ ] cook
i mean i wasn't screaming because i
don't want to wake up my kid but my wife
heard it
why was that you know just like what was
that it was just
it was just me being me so we got
married people in here who's married
that's what's up look at catholic ass
boston y'all still getting married
what about just couples just regular
couples
couples okay how many how many years
together we got
how many years together we got five
three three years
three what are these guys over here
are you black what are you
he said dominican they think that's
different
yo dominicans swear they're not black
right
dominicans all day we'll swear they're
not black and then just say the n word
like what no no we could do it it's okay
it's okay
it's okay don't worry about it we're not
black but when it comes we are
and that's your girl right there how old
are you bro
and you miss how old are you 30 30 and
31 dominicans
you should be great grandparents by now
what the [ __ ] you mean you're not
married
[Applause]
y'all ever seen dominicans at 30 not
married
yo come up on stage i need to see y'all
get up on stage both y'all
get the [ __ ] up on set we need to see
this these are unicorns right here
get the [ __ ] up i need to show a crowd
we are breaking stereotypes
come across
this is nuts man you about to see
a real live relic
a dominican man and woman
30 and 31 years of age unmarried
wow man
i cannot believe this so you said you've
been
together for how long three years
they've been together oh [ __ ] let me
give you this
so that they can see you three years
you've been together man why aren't you
guys married
ask him
be careful what you wish for
will you marry me
you better put that [ __ ] ring on
though
were you married
[Applause]
all right get down there matt
i just want to let y'all know that we
were prepared if she said no hit it
[Music]
you